à chaque présidentielle c'est un terme
qui revient dans la bouche des candidats
le vote utile c'est le vote communiste
je vous appelle
[Musique]
le vote utile c'est quoi d'abord en
voici une définition toute simple donnée
par ce journaliste vote utile c'est
consiste à voter pour le candidat de son
camp qui le mieux placé pour l'emporter
plutôt que pour le candidat de son coeur
et de ses convictions voter utile
c'est donc voté par raison et ce terme
est apparu pour la première fois lors de
l'élection présidentielle de 1969 à
l'époque la gauche est divisée le parti
communiste appelle à voter pour son
candidat jacques duclos le mieux placé
pour aller au second tour mais ça ne
plaît pas du tout à michel rocard le
candidat du parti socialiste unifié ce
thème voter utile est un des plus
bizarres non utilisées de toute la
campagne on a l'impression qu'il dessert
que justement à à renforcer ce qui est
déjà tous construits et n'a besoin
d'aucun renfort
1974 nouvelles élections à droite on
appelle à voter valéry giscard d'estaing
jean marie le pen candidat du front
national a peur de se faire siphonner
des voix alors lui le vote utile il est
contre en toute hypothèse
monsieur giscard d'estaing ne sera pas
élu au premier tour et que l'on vote
pour giscard d'estaing ou que l'on vote
pour le pen ça n'apportera pas une seule
voix à monsieur françois mitterrand pas
plus que ça lui en retirera par contre
en 1995 21 ans plus tard il change
d'avis maintenant qu'il est mieux placé
qu'un de ses rivaux le vote utile c'est
lui monsieur de villiers a pratiquement
copier son programme sur celui du front
national maintenant il ya mon avis un
élément important ce qu'ils ne vote
utile à quoi peuvent servir les voix des
électeurs qui souhaitent qu'on parle de
la france au deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle et bien c'est qu'ils
reportent leurs voix sur le seul
candidat qui soit bien placé parce que
je crois que je suis bien placée pour
être au deuxième tour
mais ce n'est qu'à partir de 2002 que
l'expression émergent vraiment dans les
campagnes présidentielles à l'époque la
gauche et l'extrême gauche que lui huit
candidats les voix se disperse
catastrophe pour le ps éliminé dès le
premier tour j'assume pleinement la
responsabilité de cet échec et j'en tire
les conclusions en me retirant de la vie
politique après
2017 la question du vote utile s'invite
une nouvelle fois dans le débat
présidentiel
à gauche on n'hésite plus tôt benoît
hamon ou emmanuel macron premier tour
autant les élections précédentes au
premier tour ont voté selon ses
convictions et au second voter utile là
dès le premier tour on se pose la
question bref en 2022 le vote utile
c'est encore une fois immiscés dans la
présidentielle
que ce soit à gauche comme à droite pour
chaque candidat c'est devenu un argument
de campagne de jean luc mélenchon à
marine le pen
[Musique]